J'ai jamais très bien compris les gens, le monde qui m'entoure. Bon, c'est l'occasion d'essayer. Je suis Guillaume Hachez.
Vous écoutez Septante Minutes Avec.
Ça allez tout le monde, j'espère que vous allez bien. J'espère que vous avez passé de super bonnes vacances parce que maintenant, c'est fini.
C'est la rentrée et j'ai deux grandes nouvelles pour marquer l'occasion. Premièrement, vous l'avez remarqué, Septante Minutes a fait peau neuve, un nouveau look pour une nouvelle saison.
J'espère que le nouveau logo et le nouveau générique vous plaisent. Un mot jazz et un look rétro qui colleront super bien à ce podcast.
Et deuxièmement, pour marquer la rentrée, je vous propose aujourd'hui un entretien avec la ministre de l'Éducation, Caroline Désir.
On a abordé énormément de sujets ensemble comme le redoublement, la mixité sociale, les inégalités liées au genre. Et on a aussi parlé évidemment des nouveautés de cette rentrée scolaire.
Sans plus attendre, Caroline Désir. C'est parti. J'ai le plaisir d'être aujourd'hui avec Caroline Désir. Bonjour Caroline Désir.
Bonjour.
Vous êtes ministre de l'Enseignement pour le gouvernement de la Fédération Wallonie-Bruxelles. Tout le monde ne le sait pas, mais avant de devenir ministre, avant d'être sous les projecteurs,
vous étiez déjà, au sein du Parti socialiste, une spécialiste, une passionnée même, des questions d'enseignement.
Alors la première question que je vais vous poser avant qu'on se plonge au cœur du sujet, mais d'où vous vient cette passion exactement ?
Oui, c'est vrai. J'ai fait dix ans comme députée, comme parlementaire en commission éducation, avant de devenir ministre.
C'était à ma demande. J'avais demandé à mon parti de pouvoir siéger dans cette commission-là. Pourquoi ? Parce que je crois que c'est complètement inhérent à l'engagement d'une femme politique socialiste.
Je pense que l'école est un peu à la base de tout en fait, et certainement un levier important pour essayer de rétablir l'égalité des chances entre les enfants quoi.
On sait à quel point les études vont être déterminantes dans la vie,
d'un citoyen. Et donc il y a beaucoup--
on attend beaucoup de l'école, évidemment, mais on voit aussi malheureusement que notre système scolaire est encore aujourd'hui beaucoup trop reproducteur des inégalités sociales et que donc malgré la démocratisation de l'accès à l'école,
en termes de résultats, on voit que malheureusement, quand on vient d'un milieu socioéconomique défavorisé, on a moins de chances,
de faire des études supérieures, etc., que si on vient,
d'un milieu plus favorisé.
Donc, vous mettez ça directement en lien avec votre parti, le Parti socialiste-
Ouais
...votre identité. On vous décrit souvent comme étant rouge vif, une socialiste
vraiment pur jus. Est-ce que ça veut dire qu'à ce moment-là, tous les membres du Parti socialiste auraient pu être à votre place et que finalement, c'est tombé sur vous un peu par hasard ?
Ou est-ce que vraiment-
Mais-
...est-ce que vraiment, vous, il y a quelque chose chez vous ?
Je m'impliquais depuis longtemps dans ces matières. Donc au moment où mon parti a décidé d'endosser cette responsabilité dans le gouvernement-
Oui, tout à fait
...ben, je faisais partie des choix. Mais c'est vrai que souvent, je dis que pour moi, tous les socialistes devraient toujours revendiquer le portefeuille de l'enseignement, tant c'est important-
Mh
...dans une société, tant c'est des combats-
Et ça a longtemps été un ministère réservé aux-
Voilà. Et, ben, le combat-
...aux siégeages
...pour l'égalité fait partie inhérent des valeurs socialistes. Donc, je pense effectivement que c'est important.
Ça faisait effectivement quinze ans qu'on n'avait plus eu ce portefeuille. Ici, on est en train de mener une réforme très très importante dont l'objectif essentiel est justement de lutter contre les inégalités
qui caractérisent trop fort notre système scolaire.
Et donc voilà, moi, je me retrouve bien dans ces combats, ça, c'est clair.
Mh.
Alors, on attend, je disais beaucoup de l'école. L'école peut pas tout toute seule, notamment dans la lutte contre la pauvreté.
Mais il y a aussi quand même des enfants qui ont la chance d'en sortir grâce à l'école quoi. Et je crois qu'on doit maximiser ces chances-là.
Alors, je le disais, on va explorer un paquet de sujets ensemble aujourd'hui. À commencer évidemment par les deux grands changements de cette nouvelle année scolaire de la Fédération Wallonie-Bruxelles,
la grille des vacances scolaires et le fameux tronc commun.
Mais avant d'explorer ces questions-là,
j'aimerais commencer par une question toute simple. Vous allez enchaîner ces prochaines semaines de nombreuses interviews, voilà, pour couvrir le volet communication de cette rentrée.
Ça s'annonce épuisant pour vous. Est-ce que lorsque vous communiquez sur ces questions, vous remarquez une certaine inertie, un certain conservatisme, une certaine résistance au changement ?
Puisque je crois remarquer quand vous communiquez sur ces questions, qu'il y a toute une série de levées de boucliers, de : "On ne peut pas toucher à mes vacances, on ne peut pas toucher à mon programme scolaire."
Est-ce que vous le remarquez ? Et comment est-ce que vous l'expliquez ?
Oui, ben, je pense que de manière générale, les gens n'aiment pas le changement. Et en plus, je dirais que l'enseignement touche absolument tout le monde.
C'est peut-être ça qui est compliqué.
Tout le monde est concerné de près ou de loin par l'école, soit parce qu'on a des enfants qui sont à l'école, soit parce que les adolescents eux-mêmes sont à l'école, parce que, ben, il y a quand même cent vingt mille enseignants, plus,
tout le personnel qui travaille dans les écoles.
Ça touche énormément de monde dans une société, l'école. Et puis les gens n'aiment pas le changement, c'est compliqué. Ça modifie les habitudes.
Je crois que ça vaut pour absolument tous les sujets. Regardez ce qui se passe autour de la mobilité aujourd'hui.
Les gens n'aiment pas le changement, donc c'est difficile. Et imposer des gros changements qui touchent à la vie des gens, des citoyens, ben, c'est compliqué.
Si on le fait, c'est évidemment pas sans raison, notamment sur le dossier des rythmes scolaires, on va y arriver.
C'est un dossier qui est sur la table depuis trente ans et derrière, il y a des scientifiques qui se sont exprimés sur la question.
Si on le fait, c'est parce qu'on est vraiment convaincus du bien-fondé de cette réforme, pour les enfants, pour les élèves et aussi pour les enseignants.
Et donc il y a derrière, voilà, je m'attends pas, quand j'annonce des réformes comme ça, à ce que ça se passe de manière, enfin- ...à long fleuve tranquille.
Mais ceci dit, il y a aussi des partisans de cette réforme. Donc, sur ce sujet-là, par exemple, c'est vraiment un peu cinquante cinquante.
Voilà, j'espère qu'à l'usage, on parviendra à convaincre. Mais vous savez, si on a peur de faire des réformes quand on est ministre, ben, il faut pas s'engager dans cette voie-là.
Parce que c'est difficile, évidemment, et parfois, il faut-- d'abord, évidemment, il faut bien préparer les réformes, il faut s'entourer des experts qu'il faut, etc.
Mais après, il faut un moment garder le cap et puis évaluer. Et si à un moment, il y a des adaptations à faire, il faut les faire.
Mais je pense qu'on ne peut pas avoir peur dès qu'il y a l'une ou l'autre voix qui s'élève contre.
Le secteur de l'enseignement n'est pas particulièrement plus inerte que-
Ben, je dirais, voilà, les enseignants sans doute n'aiment pas tellement le changement, ils n'aiment pas tellement surtout qu'on leur dise qu'ils doivent faire à leur place.
Donc, un peu quand même.
Oui, je crois que, ben, ils se sentent légitimes dans la façon dont ils font leur métier dans leur classe et c'est jamais ça qui est remis en cause.
Moi, je dois m'intéresser à ce que produit notre système scolaire de manière globale. Et peut-être que c'est ça parfois qui fait un peu défaut.
Les enseignants, parfois, n'ont pas toutes les données auxquelles nous, on a accès.
Et peut-être qu'ils se sentent vite critiqués dans leur profession, alors qu'en fait, c'est pas du tout ça l'objectif quoi, et que nous, on doit voir les choses de manière plus large.
Voilà, mais j'essaie au maximum d'expliquer ce qu'on fait. C'est pas facile, évidemment, mais je crois qu'il faut...
Une impression que j'ai, peut-être que vous allez me dire que je me trompe, c'est qu'il y a aussi une forme d'émulation de la part des professeurs de l'expérience qu'eux-mêmes ont connue ou elles-mêmes ont connue à l'école.
Et donc finalement, on reproduit l'expérience qu'on a connue quand on était-
Exact.
Sur les bancs de l'école. Et donc finalement, ça induit un certain conservatisme.
Tout à fait. Et je pense que, ben, c'est ce qu'on appelle un peu la, notre culture scolaire. On a des choses, on en parlera peut-être tout à l'heure, mais, par exemple, un très très bon exemple pour ça, c'est le redoublement. On a-
Oui, on va en parler, oui.
Voilà, on fait chez nous un recours complètement massif au redoublement, hors norme.
On recrute au redoublement.
Oui, et on est les champions du monde du redoublement.
Ouais, c'est vrai.
Et malgré aujourd'hui toute la recherche scientifique qui nous prouve que c'est inefficace sur le plan pédagogique, on est encore très attachés à ça.
Les enseignants sont très attachés au redoublement, mais aussi les parents, parfois, pensent vraiment que c'est encore une bonne manière de remettre un élève en difficulté en selle.
Et c'est difficile de lutter contre ce genre de choses parce qu'en fait, ça fait partie un peu des tabous de notre enseignement.
Et on doit pourtant amorcer un changement de culture à ce niveau-là. Je crois que c'est vraiment important.
On peut en parler maintenant. C'est à la fois une question de, vous le disiez, les sciences de l'éducation qui confirment que ce n'est pas une bonne solution pour les élèves de redoubler.
C'est aussi une question de budget. Ça coûte très cher à la Fédération Wallonie-Bruxelles. Qu'est-ce que vous constatez sur le terrain ?
Quelle est la réception à l'idée qu'il faut faire moins de redoublement ? Est-ce que les professeurs-- Parce qu'on est évidemment dans un enseignement libre, ce qui fait que beaucoup de professeurs, finalement, gardent une certaine autonomie,
ce qui va main en main avec la question du conservatisme dont on parlait il y a un instant.
C'est-à-dire que, mais la ministre, elle va quand même pas me dire comment je dois faire mon travail, je suis libre. Est-ce que vous êtes à même, finalement, de freiner cette culture du redoublement ?
Mais donc, justement, là, de nouveau, je dois un peu partir des constats et de la recherche parce que ça fait, en fait, déjà des dizaines d'années qu'on tourne autour de cette question.
Il y a déjà de la recherche en sciences de l'éducation dans les années 80, mais confirmée après, dans les années 90, 2000, partout dans le monde, qui démontre de manière claire
qu'un enfant, un adolescent qu'on fait redoubler va un peu s'améliorer l'année du redoublement, mais en fait, il va moins s'améliorer que si on l'avait laissé passer dans la classe supérieure à difficultés scolaires égales.
Et ça, c'est quand même interpellant. Et donc toutes les recherches sont unanimes là-dessus. Ben simplement, les enseignants, souvent, ils ont pas accès à ces recherches.
On leur explique pas ça pendant leur formation initiale. Et donc, je pense que c'est de toute bonne foi qu'ils continuent aujourd'hui à faire doubler des élèves en difficulté.
Mais quand je disais tout à l'heure que le recours qu'on fait au redoublement en Fédération Wallonie-Bruxelles est un peu délirant, j'ai des chiffres là-dessus.
Donc, on a les, vous savez, les fameuses études PISA qui nous montrent où on se situe par rapport aux autres pays de l'OCDE.
Et donc chez nous, à quinze ans, on a plus de 45 % des élèves qui ont déjà doublé au moins une année. La moyenne des pays de l'OCDE, sur cette question du retard, 'fin, des élèves en retard ou à l'heure, c'est 13 %.
Donc nous, on est au-dessus de 45 %, la moyenne, c'est 13 %. Et alors, des pays comme le Royaume-Uni ou la Finlande sont à 2 %.
Et vous parlez beaucoup de la Finlande.
Oui, mais parce que c'est-- la Finlande, c'est toujours un peu l'exemple des modèles d'éducation parfaits.
Toujours, toujours.
J'en parle pas trop parce que je pense qu'on peut pas tout transposer.
Vous en parlez beaucoup.
Oui, et avant moi, tous les ministres de l'Éducation.
Mais voilà, ce qui est intéressant de dire aussi, c'est que c'est le cas aussi dans d'autres pays scandinaves, dans des pays de l'Europe du Sud, dans les pays anglo-saxons, au Canada.
Ce sont des pays où on a une logique d'enseignement qui est beaucoup plus inclusive, où il paraîtrait complètement incongru de séparer un enfant des autres enfants de son âge parce qu'il est en difficulté scolaire.
Et ce sont des pays où le redoublement existe quasiment pas et où on a un tronc commun en général jusque quinze, seize ans.
Et pourtant, pour autant, ce ne sont pas des pays qui ont des moins bons résultats que nous dans les classements PISA, par exemple, loin de là même.
Donc, tout ça pour dire que notre culture scolaire est fort imprégnée de cette culture du redoublement, mais que c'est pas quelque chose qui est unanimement partagé dans le monde.
Donc, on pourrait faire autrement. Et donc, on a, par exemple, encore beaucoup de parents et d'enseignants aujourd'hui qui nous disent : "Oui, mais si on n'a plus la menace du redoublement, un peu le bâton,
on perd la motivation des élèves, surtout dans le secondaire."
C'est vraiment un argument qu'on entend souvent. C'est un peu bizarre parce qu'il y a plein d'autres systèmes qui parviennent à motiver des élèves autrement, en donnant du sens aux apprentissages, à l'école, etc.
Simplement en essayant d'emmener les enfants chacun vers le meilleur d'eux-mêmes. Et donc voilà, je pense qu'il y a tout ça à changer.
Alors, maintenant, après les constats, peut-être un peu les réponses. Donc le pacte a décidé de ne pas interdire purement et simplement le redoublement.
Pourquoi ? Parce que ça, on a déjà essayé par le passé, mes prédécesseurs, sur certaines années, etc.
Ça fonctionne assez mal parce qu'en première secondaire, par exemple, pour l'instant, on ne peut pas doubler, mais finalement, on voit qu'il y a un rattrapage l'année suivante.
Donc c'est pas des solutions structurelles. Et donc ce qu'on a décidé de faire, c'est pas interdire le redoublement, mais de se fixer un objectif ambitieux de réduction,
du taux de redoublement, de cinquante pour cent à l'horizon deux mille trente.
Alors comment on fait ? Y a pas de baguette magique, dire aux enseignants, faites doubler deux fois moins, c'est pas ça l'idée.
Surtout que tout ce qui a échoué précédemment, c'est aussi parce qu'on dit aux enseignants ne faites plus redoubler, mais on donne pas d'autres outils aux enseignants pour faire autrement.
Donc voilà, ça ne marche pas. Et donc, avec le pacte, ce qu'on a décidé de faire, c'est de travailler sur toute une série de réformes conjointement pour soutenir les enseignants dans cet objectif de réduction du redoublement.
Alors la première chose, c'est un des axes fondamentaux de cette réforme du pacte, c'est la réforme de la gouvernance, du pilotage de nos écoles.
Vous imaginez, en Fédération Wallonie-Bruxelles, il y a deux mille cinq cents écoles différentes.
Quand on se fixe au niveau de la Fédération un objectif de réduction du redoublement de cinquante pour cent à l'horizon deux mille trente, comment on fait pour embarquer deux mille cinq cents écoles avec nous dans cet objectif ?
Et donc la réponse à ça, ça a été de demander aux écoles, à chacune des deux mille cinq cents écoles, de rédiger un plan de pilotage en équipe pédagogique,
en se fixant elles-mêmes des objectifs qui rentrent dans le cadre des objectifs généraux que la Fédération Wallonie-Bruxelles s'est fixée, dont cette réduction du redoublement.
Et donc une fois que l'école a réfléchi en équipe à comment atteindre ces objectifs-là, elle signe un contrat, donc elle contractualise, si vous voulez, ce plan de pilotage avec la Fédération Wallonie-Bruxelles.
C'est-à-dire que son plan de pilotage va être évalué à trois ans et puis au-delà,
avec ce qu'on appelle un DCO, donc un délégué au contrat objectif, qui représente en fait la Fédération Wallonie-Bruxelles, à l'échelle de cette école.
Donc ça, c'est une première chose, c'est-à-dire que chaque école a elle-même des objectifs qu'elle s'est assignés en termes de réduction du redoublement.
Et alors ensuite, comment on fait concrètement, finalement, face aux difficultés des élèves ? Parce que c'est un peu ça, évidemment, le nerf de la guerre.
Donc, vous savez peut-être pas d'ailleurs que, on a fondamentalement revu ce parcours d'apprentissage de l'élève.
On a commencé déjà avec l'enseignement maternel il y a deux ans. Maintenant, c'est une rentrée un peu cruciale puisque ce sont les élèves de première et deuxième primaire qui vont faire leur entrée dans le tronc commun.
Ça veut dire qu'on a revu fondamentalement tous les contenus.
On va parler du tronc commun dans un instant.
J'y reviendrai après. OK, ben voilà. Je garde ça pour tout à l'heure. Mais ce qui est intéressant, c'est qu'au-delà de ces contenus modifiés, en même temps va entrer en vigueur l'accompagnement personnalisé.
C'est-à-dire que, dans la grille horaire des élèves, pendant minimum deux périodes par semaine, maximum quatre périodes par semaine, on va consacrer du temps à résoudre les difficultés d'apprentissage, consacrer du temps à suivre
chaque enfant à son rythme.
Et pour ça, on va engager des enseignants supplémentaires ou des logopèdes, etc. C'est-à-dire qu'il y a des moments-
Alors ça pose beaucoup de questions. Donc déjà, effectivement, quand on entend l'opposition à ces réformes liées au redoublement,
les témoignages qu'on entend souvent, c'est que, mais, les élèves qui ratent, ils vont en payer le prix l'année suivante, ils vont pas pouvoir suivre, etc.
Donc ces formes de rattrapage, d'assistance pour les élèves qui en ont le besoin, ça résoudrait le problème d'après vous ?
Est-ce que ça suffit ?
D'abord, évidemment, c'est intéressant de s'intéresser aux difficultés d'apprentissage au moment où elles se posent et de pas les laisser s'accumuler.
C'est ça qui se passe pour l'instant. Et en plus, quelque part, ça vient renforcer les inégalités entre élèves qui sont déjà préexistantes, évidemment, à la différenciation sociale.
Oui, parce que tu peux pas avoir de professeurs particuliers.
Voilà. Les parents qui ont les moyens, en fait, ils suppléent aux difficultés scolaires grâce à des profs particuliers, des logopèdes, etc.
Donc l'idée, c'est vraiment de rapatrier au sein de l'école ce soutien aux élèves et de consacrer du temps à la différenciation.
C'est-à-dire, on a des élèves qui apprennent plus vite que d'autres, qui ont des formes d'intelligence différentes, etc. Et donc,
c'est consacrer du temps à ça. Pour ça, on privilégie comme modèle le co-enseignement, c'est-à-dire des périodes où on aura soit deux enseignants dans la même classe,
soit un enseignant et un logopède ou un enseignant et un autre type de profil.
Et donc ça, c'est important parce qu'en fait pour l'instant, ça existe pas. Y a pas un moment où on se pose pour se dire-
Il y a une raison pourquoi ça n'existe pas. Parce que très peu de profs. On a beaucoup de mal à en trouver. C'est un métier qui attire peu, que beaucoup décrivent comme mal payé, stressant.
Et votre plan se base sur le fait qu'il faut beaucoup, beaucoup de staff en plus.
Oui. D'abord, ça va pas se faire du jour au lendemain. Je vous ai dit que c'était fort progressif. On commence avec les premières, deuxièmes primaires l'année prochaine.
Vous savez qu'on sort d'une période où on avait injecté, entre guillemets, des périodes Covid pour soutenir un peu justement les difficultés scolaires en classe.
Ça veut dire qu'il y a toute une série de membres du personnel qui étaient engagés sur ces périodes-là, qu'on va pouvoir peut-être réengager dans le cadre du temps scolaire.
Après, on parle de deux à quatre périodes, donc ce sont pas des,
des horaires complets. Ça veut dire que des professeurs soit vont pouvoir compléter leur horaire, soit vont pouvoir travailler dans plusieurs établissements.
Donc, je suis pas inquiète pour cette année-ci. Le problème de la pénurie, c'est un problème vaste qui est pas ni propre à la réforme du tronc commun, ni même propre à la Fédération Wallonie-Bruxelles.
On le rencontre absolument dans tous les pays européens. On le rencontre très très fortement en Flandre pour le moment. Et je sais pas si vous avez un peu entendu parler de ça, mais on le rencontre dans l'ensemble des PME.
Enfin, il y a quand même une pénurie dans différents secteurs et différents métiers. Ça veut dire qu'on doit travailler-
Ça ne résout pas le problème.
Non, non, mais ça veut dire qu'on doit évidemment, enfin c'est multifactoriel aussi. Il suffit pas de dire-- moi, j'ai pas de baguette magique pour créer des professeurs.
Je dis souvent ça, vous savez, bon. Et donc on doit à la fois travailler sur l'attractivité du métier.
Ça, objectivement, c'est ce qu'on est en train de faire à travers une grande réforme de notre système scolaire.
C'est essayer de revaloriser notre enseignement. C'est aussi créer des conditions de travail de qualité et notamment ces petites périodes de co-enseignement, ça en fait partie.
Ça permet aussi d'un peu échanger des bonnes pratiques entre pairs. Ça permet de pas se retrouver tout seul tout le temps face à une classe, de confronter des points de vue. Tout ça-
Et au niveau de l'attractivité, les revenus des professeurs, est-ce que c'est quelque chose qui va être revu à la hausse ou ?
Ben alors, vous savez, dans le cadre de la réforme de la formation initiale, vous savez qu'on va passer la formation initiale de trois ans à quatre ans.
Il semble logique que ça amène une revalorisation barème.
Très bien.
Voilà.
Les syndicats aussi, ça leur semble logique évidemment. Et donc ce qu'on a convenu avec eux, c'est qu'on va préparer maintenant le terrain
pour quand cette première cohorte de futurs enseignants sortira
dans la nouvelle mouture, on va dire, de la formation initiale, pour essayer de trouver un nouveau barème qui soit entre le barème trois cent existant et cinq cent un.
Maintenant, voilà, on ne va pas non plus se mentir, c'est un coût colossal pour la Fédération de Bruxelles qui est déjà dans une situation financière plus ou moins inextricable puisque vous savez qu'on n'a pas de leviers fiscaux.
Oui, Philippe Moerkerke parle souvent de la Fédération Wallonie-Bruxelles comme étant quelque chose de fondamentalement déficitaire.
Oui parce qu'on voit aujourd'hui qu'on a une série de coûts qui augmentent sans cesse alors qu'on n'a pas de leviers pour augmenter nos recettes.
On dépend d'une dotation du fédéral. Donc c'est effectivement très très compliqué. C'est pas-- Vous voyez, enfin, on ne peut pas faire des économies dans l'enseignement, dans la culture.
Enfin, c'est extrêmement compliqué.
Ben le redoublement sera déjà une forme d'économie, mais peut-être pas suffisante.
Voilà. Et donc, il y a des grosses questions qui se posent sur l'avenir de la Fédération Bruxelles et qui sont liées étroitement à ces négociations à venir sur le barème.
Mais si vous me posez la question, voilà. Si vous me posez la question, voilà, si on augmente la durée des études des enseignants, est-ce qu'il est logique qu'ils soient payés davantage ?
Oui, je pense que la réponse est oui, pour moi. Voilà, ça me-
Parce que c'est logique. Bon, ce n'est pas tout à fait une promesse, mais c'est un sentiment de votre part.
Je comprends que ce soit une demande et je voudrais vraiment que la Fédération Wallonie-Bruxelles puisse y répondre.
Maintenant, ceci dit, c'est pas non plus toujours la première revendication des syndicats. Je les rencontre très très souvent, on est beaucoup en concertation autour du pacte.
On va dire qu'ils sont pas plaintifs au niveau de leurs conditions salariales. Évidemment que
ils revendiquent une augmentation du barème liée à la réforme de la formation initiale, c'est logique, mais c'est pas parmi leurs premières demandes quoi.
J'entends plus de demandes sur la taille des classes, les conditions de travail, etc.
On va en parler aussi.
Ils le disent eux-mêmes souvent : Nous, on n'est pas toujours en train de demander plus d'argent, c'est pas notre première préoccupation.
Il y a beaucoup d'autres choses à faire par ailleurs quoi.
Oui. Donc justement, la question des aménagements dont on peut parler aussi, les élèves avec, vous le disiez, des formes d'intelligence différentes.
La question de la neurodiversité est très chère à mes yeux. Donc, on peut parler par exemple des personnes autistes, des personnes avec un trouble de l'attention, des personnes avec une dyscalculie, une dyslexie.
Voilà, toute une série de profils différents. Jusqu'à présent, il y avait un petit peu soit une ignorance complète de ces questions et ces élèves étaient stigmatisés de ne pas travailler assez dur, assez bien,
soit il y avait un culte du,
de l'enseignement spécialisé.
Quelle est la place pour ces élèves dans le nouveau pacte pour un enseignement d'excellence ?
Mais donc, parmi les objectifs du pacte,
un est très très important, c'est de faire en sorte que notre école soit plus inclusive, c'est-à-dire qu'elle accueille
fondamentalement des profils plus diversifiés d'enfants, quels que soient, on parlait tout à l'heure des difficultés scolaires, ici, ben, c'est parfois des troubles d'apprentissage, etc.
Je parlais tout à l'heure d'autres modèles d'enseignement qui sont beaucoup plus inclusifs. C'est vrai que le nôtre se caractérise plutôt par sorte de délestage progressif de tous les élèves qui ne rentrent pas dans la norme.
On peut s'arrêter là-dessus juste un instant. Est-ce que vous avez le sentiment que dans, voilà, on parlait de notre culture de l'enseignement ici en Belgique francophone,
est-ce qu'il y a une culture de l'élitisme, une culture du, si on ne travaille pas dur, on,
on est laissé tomber, on doit recommencer, on doit en payer le prix ?
On a un système scolaire qui est vraiment fort basé sur la relégation. En fait, c'est, ben les chercheurs appellent même ça l'effet toboggan.
Donc, soit on est dans la norme, dans le moule et on poursuit ses études dans l'enseignement général, soit à un moment, on diverge de la norme pour toute une série de raisons et alors on est
orienté au fur et à mesure vers l'enseignement spécialisé, le redoublement, une première différenciée, enseignement qualifiant, enseignement professionnel.
Voilà, c'est vraiment-- Notre système scolaire est conçu comme ça. Et ça, il faut vraiment comprendre, ça fait partie des constats à la base du pacte
et c'est aussi sur ça qu'on essaye de travailler grâce au tronc commun sur lequel on reviendra plus tard.
Mais pour revenir à votre question, par rapport aux enfants qui ont des besoins spécifiques, de manière générale, il faut apporter une réponse, je pense, nuancée.
D'abord, on peut beaucoup mieux faire en termes d'inclusion et c'est ce à quoi on va s'engager au travers de la réforme des pôles territoriaux.
Je vais y revenir dans un instant. À côté de ça, on a un enseignement spécialisé de qualité que certains voisins nous envient.
D'ailleurs, on a énormément d'enfants français, par exemple, qui viennent en Belgique parce qu'il n'y a pas d'école qui répond à leurs besoins dans leur pays.
Et donc on doit pas être caricatural, je pense, dans cette réponse. C'est-à-dire que pour un certain nombre d'enfants, l'enseignement spécialisé va répondre à leurs besoins de manière adéquate.
On a des super professionnels de l'enseignement spécialisé que j'ai vraiment découverts au fur et à mesure de mon mandat.
Mais ce qui nous intéresse aussi ici, c'est de se dire comment faire en sorte qu'une série d'enfants qui pourraient continuer leur scolarité dans l'enseignement ordinaire puissent le faire en bénéficiant d'un accompagnement adéquat.
Ça, c'est la question que je voudrais vraiment résoudre à travers cette réforme des pôles territoriaux,
parce que simplement, on a, par rapport à d'autres pays, trop d'enfants qui sont scolarisés dans l'enseignement spécialisé.
Et donc on voudrait revenir à une juste proportion et garder l'enseignement spécialisé, ceux qui en ont vraiment besoin.
Alors, comment est-ce qu'on fait ça ? On a eu une première réforme il y a quelques années qui s'appelle l'intégration.
Donc on avait des enfants qui bénéficiaient en fait de l'accompagnement de l'enseignement spécialisé dans l'enseignement ordinaire.
Mais ce qu'on a constaté, c'est que
ça dépendait un peu trop du bon vouloir des écoles. On a des écoles qui se sont lancées à fond dans l'intégration, qui en ont fait un projet d'établissement et d'autres écoles ou même d'autres régions où ça se passait pas du tout.
Et donc les enfants étaient systématiquement parce qu'ils étaient dyslexiques, dyscalculiques, TDAH, etc. Systématiquement renvoyés vers l'enseignement spécialisé alors qu'ils auraient pu poursuivre dans l'ordinaire.
Et donc on a décidé de faire une grosse remise à plat du système de l'intégration en créant les pôles territoriaux. Les pôles territoriaux, ils vont démarrer en septembre.
Enfin, en septembre, vingt-neuf août prochain. J'ai encore moi-même m'habituer. Donc, on aura quarante-huit pôles territoriaux qui vont être créés.
Les pôles territoriaux, c'est une structure attachée à l'enseignement spécialisé et chaque école en fait de l'enseignement ordinaire va devoir passer une convention avec un pôle territorial.
Donc chaque école de l'ordinaire va être obligée de travailler avec un pôle territorial. Pourquoi ? Parce que comme ça, quand elle va constater qu'un enfant, par exemple, a un diagnostic de dyslexie.
Oui, donc ça part du principe que ces élèves sont proprement diagnostiqués.
Oui.
Et si je reprends l'exemple de l'autisme, à l'instant, en Belgique, c'est catastrophique. C'est pas le cas.
Oui, oui, on va y revenir. La question du diagnostic est vraiment-
Centrale
...est vraiment centrale et vraiment un problème. On a aussi les PMS pour orienter les parents sur cette question et les enseignants qui sont un peu, eux ne peuvent pas poser de diagnostic.
Évidemment, ce n'est pas leur métier, mais ils sont quand même... Le but évidemment, c'est de les former à la détection précoce de tout ça aussi.
Et donc un enfant qui aurait par exemple un diagnostic de dyslexie ou de multi-dys ou dyscalculie.
Les parents contactent l'école et l'école va prendre contact avec le pôle territorial pour qu'on
établisse pour l'enfant un protocole d'aménagement raisonnable, c'est-à-dire de déterminer quels sont les besoins de cet enfant pour qu'il puisse continuer sa scolarité dans l'enseignement ordinaire.
Parfois, ça va être un accompagnement en classe de l'enfant et parfois, et c'est surtout aussi sur ça qu'on mise, ça va être une formation spéciale de son enseignant à ce qu'il doit mettre en place pour accueillir convenablement son élève.
Ce que le changement de paradigme réel, là de nouveau, c'est toute la littérature qui nous l'enseigne, c'est d'arriver à former les enseignants de l'ordinaire au changement.
Il y a beaucoup de boulot parce que jusqu'ici, la formation initiale des enseignants contenait vraiment qu'une toute toute toute petite part consacrée aux enfants à besoins spécifiques.
Les enseignants me disent en général, c'est une demi-journée de formation sur nos trois ans, vous imaginez ? Alors qu'il y a des enfants à besoins spécifiques absolument dans toutes les classes.
On essaie de pallier ce problème via la formation continue, mais c'est encore insuffisant. Et donc ici, l'idée, c'est que
ces pôles territoriaux, ils vont être constitués autour d'un coordonnateur, d'une équipe pluridisciplinaire, avec tous les métiers de l'enseignement spécialisé, donc des instituteurs, des logopèdes, des ergothérapeutes, etc.
Tous ayant une formation spécifique pour les enfants à besoins spécifiques ou les enfants porteurs de handicap.
Et donc cette expertise du spécialisé qu'on est allé chercher pour constituer les pôles, on veut la mettre au service de l'enseignement ordinaire pour améliorer l'accueil des enfants à besoins spécifiques et leur permettre de poursuivre en ordinaire.
Donc-
Et là, le vrai changement, c'est que toutes les écoles de l'enseignement ordinaire vont devoir monter dans le train cette fois-ci.
Donc plus d'inclusivité, plus d'aménagements. Quand on parle d'écoles où les classes sont déjà très fortement remplies, est-ce que c'est réaliste de parler d'aménagements, de demander aux professeurs, même s'ils sont assistés,
de gérer des cas un peu différents, un peu spécifiques,
alors qu'ils sont déjà débordés par des classes de parfois trente élèves ?
C'est une crainte très très souvent exprimée par les enseignants que je rencontre. Et en réalité, quand on fait un peu le tour des classes de primaire par exemple, moi, je vais souvent visiter les écoles,
les enfants à besoins spécifiques y sont dans les classes déjà.
Oui, bien sûr, bien sûr.
Il y en a partout et d'ailleurs, ils sont beaucoup mieux diagnostiqués qu'avant. Et donc voilà, dans chaque classe, il y a des enfants dyslexiques, TDAH, etc.
Et donc aujourd'hui, les professeurs, ils doivent déjà gérer cette hétérogénéité de profils. Simplement, ils n'ont pas les outils et ils n'ont pas la formation pour le faire.
Donc c'est ça qu'on veut absolument améliorer. Après, je dirais qu'il y a autant de besoins spécifiques que d'élèves qui sont différents.
Donc c'est important de formaliser les choses avec un protocole parce que
un enfant, par exemple TDAH, il peut avoir comme besoin par exemple d'être mis
au milieu de la classe devant pour focaliser son attention ou de pouvoir bénéficier, je ne sais pas, d'un petit casque à certains moments de la journée ou des choses comme ça,
mais qui nécessitent pas pour autant un accompagnement au quotidien à côté de lui quoi.
À côté de ça, on peut avoir un enfant très très largement dyspraxique-
Donc l'aménagement, c'est pas si dur que ça finalement.
Mais ça dépend. En fait, ça dépend complètement. Mais il y a des choses où c'est aussi simplement un manque de connaissance de ce que c'est une dyslexie.
Et alors on parle aussi beaucoup des aménagements universels. J'espère qu'un jour, on y arrivera. Ça, c'est typiquement des enfants qui ont besoin d'une police spéciale, de ne pas faire
des consignes en recto verso, d'avoir certains mots clés.
Mais à un moment donné, on le voit fort pour les épreuves externes CEB, CE1D où il y a des aménagements particuliers pour certains enfants.
On se dit mais pourquoi finalement ne pas systématiser ça à tout le monde ? Puisque c'est pas très grave qu'un enfant ordinaire ait une police, j'invente, mais Arial quatorze, ça ne change rien pour lui.
Or, pour l'enfant qui a un besoin spécifique, c'est très très important. Donc ça aussi, ce sont des pratiques qui progressivement...
Mais il y a beaucoup d'expertises à aller chercher dans l'enseignement spécialisé. Et voilà, ici, on voudrait en faire bénéficier l'enseignement ordinaire.
Donc on croit beaucoup quand même à cette réforme, même si comme toutes les réformes, elle fait grincer des dents, elle fait peur.
Encore une fois, beaucoup d'inertie, beaucoup de conservatisme.
Oui. Mais donc et principalement, je dirais dans les écoles qui pratiquaient déjà beaucoup l'intégration, qui sont très rodées à ça et qui se disent mais nous, on travaille bien, pourquoi est-ce qu'on vient tout nous changer ?
Mais justement parce qu'il y a plein d'écoles où ce n'est pas du tout le cas. Or, on sait qu'il y a des enfants à besoins spécifiques partout sur le territoire de la Fédération et Bruxelles.
Et donc il n'y a pas de raison que dans certains lieux, ils soient bien pris en charge et d'autres lieux pas.
Alors, on va, je le disais, on n'arrête pas de le repousser à plus tard, mais on va explorer les questions de calendrier scolaire et de tronc commun.
Mais juste avant ça, j'aimerais juste clôturer cette question d'inclusivité de,
d'élèves avec des profils atypiques. Hum, j'avais eu l'occasion d'interviewer il y a quelques années quelqu'un que vous connaissez, Jérôme Colin, qui me parlait de son fils.
Il vous en a sans doute parlé aussi. Donc il a fait le choix de, face à un fils qui éprouvait beaucoup de frustration, d'inconfort, ne pas être à sa place dans l'enseignement,
tel qu'il est présent aujourd'hui en Belgique, de finalement écouter son fils et de dire : Bon ben en fait, ça ne te convient pas, tu ne dois plus aller à l'école.
Les témoignages comme ça, de frustration par rapport à l'enseignement tel qu'il existe aujourd'hui, est-ce que c'est quelque chose que vous pouvez entendre, comprendre qu'un parent puisse dire : Ben ça ne va pas, on arrête tout.
Oui, ben, ce n'est pas malheureusement un cas unique. Et en plus, je dirais que on vient de vivre des années qui sont quand même particulièrement difficiles.
Et je ne sais pas du tout si c'est lié dans son cas, mais je veux dire, on a quand même une série d'adolescents qui ne vont pas très bien suite à cette crise et qui ont vu leur rapport à l'école complètement chamboulé par ça.
Moi, je pense qu'il faut redonner du sens à l'école, du sens aux apprentissages, au-delà des crises multiples qu'on vit entre la crise sanitaire, crise climatique, etc.
Qui impacte quand même beaucoup le moral des jeunes, des adolescents. On a aussi un rapport au savoir qui est complètement modifié par rapport à ma génération.
C'est-à-dire que eux, en deux clics, ils ont accès à tout sur Internet. Et donc, comment encore intéresser des élèves à une espèce de transmission des savoirs classiques ou verticales ?
Ça ne marche plus comme ça quoi. Vraiment, il faut trouver une autre façon de faire l'école quoi, leur apprendre à réfléchir, à décortiquer,
à avoir un esprit critique, à décoder toute cette information qui finalement aujourd'hui, le problème est plus peut-être l'excès d'informations que de simplement...
Voilà, on ne peut plus aujourd'hui demander à des élèves de connaître des trucs par cœur. Ça, ça ne marche plus comme ça.
Et franchement, on ne peut plus motiver des élèves à ça comme ça.
Vous parliez de rapport au savoir, alors, je ne sais pas si c'est comme ça partout, mais en ce qui concerne ma propre expérience, je me rappelle qu'il y avait vraiment...
Alors évidemment, quand on est adolescent, l'école, c'est nonante pourcents de nos vies à peu près en termes d'occupation.
Donc, il y a vraiment un rapport de si j'échoue à l'école, j'échoue à énormément de choses dans ma vie. Et alors, c'est aussi peut-être une place très importante occupée par l'enseignement catholique ici en Belgique francophone.
Donc culture de la culpabilisation où quand on échoue, on est, je pense, vous pouvez me corriger si je me trompe, très fort stigmatisé.
Est-ce que c'est quelque chose que vous vous êtes intéressé à attaquer ? Et est-ce que vous êtes en mesure d'attaquer les questions qui sont finalement
idéologiques, philosophiques et très, très au cœur de ce qu'on appelle l'enseignement libre, finalement ?
Mais c'est, oui, c'est une question compliquée, évidemment. De nouveau, l'école—
C'est pas sympa de ma part.
Non, mais l'école, l'école peut pas tout non plus quoi. Effectivement, il y a un cadre, il y a une obligation scolaire hein, jusqu'à dix-huit ans, quelle que soit la forme.
Parce que pour revenir sur l'exemple de Jérôme Colin, on peut aussi décider et certains font le choix de ça, de faire de l'école à domicile, d'autres formes d'enseignement, des jurys.
Enfin voilà, il y a encore d'autres manières aussi. Mais l'idée au départ quand même est, je pense, positive de se dire que tout le monde a besoin d'un bagage minimum pour affronter la vie en société.
Et c'est aussi au départ une question liée à la démocratisation de l'accès à l'école et au fait que tout le monde doit avoir les mêmes chances.
Après, voilà, on est dans un monde en mutation rapide. C'est pas évident pour l'école, je pense, de s'adapter à ça. Et donc je crois que c'était aussi
pour nous important dans le cadre de cette réforme du Pacte de se dire : prenons le temps aussi de se poser pour fondamentalement revoir les contenus de ce qu'on doit apprendre à l'école au vingt-et-unième siècle en fait.
Parce que c'est sans doute une institution qui a le moins changé ces cinquante dernières années quoi. Aujourd'hui, on fait encore l'école terriblement comme à mon époque et peut-être même à l'époque de mes parents.
Or, le monde est en mutation de manière rapide quoi. Et donc c'est un sacré défi que j'ai pas évidemment relevé moi toute seule à mon bureau, je vous rassure.
Mais il y a des panels d'experts qui sont réunis pendant quasiment quatre ans pour redéfinir les contenus de ces fameux nouveaux référentiels.
Ça veut dire matière par matière, année après année.
Donc là, vous parlez vraiment des référentiels, des,
des programmes d'enseignement. Ma question portait plutôt sur la philosophie de l'enseignement, le rapport à l'enseignement, la culpabilisation très présente, je pense, dans l'enseignement catholique, ici en Belgique francophone.
Est-ce que ça, ce sont des questions qui pourraient changer ou bien est-ce que c'est mal barré ?
Je dirais que c'est difficile à aborder comme ça. Par contre, on aborde par certains biais comme la question du redoublement, mais aussi qui est très fort liée la question de l'évaluation.
Alors, redoublement, pourquoi je pense à ça ? Parce que parmi les effets vraiment néfastes du redoublement qui font qu'aujourd'hui, moi, personnellement, je suis convaincue que c'est une pratique pédagogique néfaste.
Parce que les effets en termes d'estime de soi et de confiance en soi, ils sont catastrophiques. C'est-à-dire qu'un enfant
qui, surtout dans un jeune âge, a été amené à redoubler, va intégrer l'idée qu'il est incapable et donc va, et ça aussi, c'est mesuré par les scientifiques, va revoir ses aspirations scolaires et puis professionnelles à la baisse.
Ça veut dire qu'on crée des dégâts qui vont marquer en fait un enfant ou un adolescent au fer rouge pour toute sa vie. Et donc c'est quand même pas rien.
Parce qu'on parle de la moitié des élèves de la Fédération Wallonie-Bruxelles hein. Alors, je dis pas tous qu'ils vont être traumatisés parce qu'ils ont redoublé.
Attention, il faut toujours être nuancé, mais on constate quand même qu'il y a des impacts sur l'estime de soi.
Et ça, je pense que,
c'est vraiment une chose à laquelle on doit être attentif. Et parallèlement à ça, et je dois dire que je suis assez contente de voir que
dans toutes les fédérations de pouvoir organisateur, il y a quand même une réflexion qui est en train de s'amorcer autour de ça.
La question des évaluations est fondamentale. On a de nouveau un système très classique avec des sessions d'examens à différents moments clés de l'année
qui prennent beaucoup de temps dans le cursus en fait, hein, qui sont quand même des moments formalisés, autour desquels tout tourne dans notre système scolaire, qui tombent comme des couperets,
et qui déterminent des parcours scolaires.
Il se trouve qu'aujourd'hui, dans tous les réseaux d'enseignement,
il y a quand même cette envie d'avoir une réflexion, d'avoir cette deuxième session sur, oui, le temps qu'on consacre à ces évaluations sommatives et surtout sur la manière de faire autrement,
c'est-à-dire de favoriser des évaluations formatives plus régulières, au fur et à mesure de la scolarité.
Et donc c'est intéressant, voilà, de mener de nouveau cette— 'fin, d'accompagner en fait ce changement de mentalité.
Je pense que de nouveau si un ministre de l'Enseignement dit : on peut plus faire d'examens, j'ose même pas imaginer les réactions.
Mais par contre, de voir que, aujourd'hui, depuis les écoles, depuis les réseaux d'enseignement, là aussi, on se dit en fait,
même s'il faut encore des moments où on revoit de manière plus générale toute la matière et on a un examen parce que c'est bien pour se préparer pour la suite, etc., O.K., mais ça doit pas être que ça.
L'évaluation, ça peut être aussi d'autres choses et ça peut être aussi simplement une manière, sans avoir
une sanction à la clé ou un risque ou une menace ordonnant, de pouvoir simplement se dire, mais où on en est par rapport à la maîtrise de certaines compétences, etc.
Qu'est-ce qu'il faut améliorer ? D'avoir plus des évaluations diagnostics, des évaluations formatives, etc. Voilà, donc ça fait partie aussi des chantiers du pacte.
Parce que, voilà, pour répondre un peu de manière détournée à votre question, je pense que ça fait aussi partie peut-être de la philosophie, et de nouveau du sens qu'on veut donner à notre enseignement.
Est-ce que le but de notre enseignement, c'est de faire réussir les élèves ou c'est de les faire échouer, en fait ?
C'est une question. On a quand même une certaine tendance à entretenir la culture de l'échec, quoi. Je dis souvent ça, mais,
dans nos mentalités en Belgique francophone, on a quand même un peu l'idée qu'une bonne école, c'est une école qui buse.
Un bon prof, c'est un prof qui a beaucoup d'échecs, ce qui est complètement paradoxal finalement, quoi.
Il y a des écoles où on commence avec des dizaines de classes en première secondaire et on termine avec—
La pyramide.
La pyramide, oui. C'est un peu cette philosophie-là, finalement.
Tout à fait. Et finalement, allez, quel est le challenge pour une école de faire réussir des bons élèves qui vont de toute façon réussir partout en se délestant de tous ceux qui ont des difficultés ?
Y a pas de challenge quoi.
Oui. Et on va justement, dans cette idée-là, parler de la mixité sociale un peu plus tard. Parlons des vacances, enfin.
Donc la réforme qui arrive cette année-ci, donc, du calendrier scolaire,
en gros, les vacances qui duraient une semaine jusqu'à présent, donc vacances d'automne ou de Toussaint, ou les vacances de carnaval, duraient jusqu'à présent une semaine et maintenant vont durer deux semaines.
Mais par contre, les vacances d'été sont un petit peu écourtées. Et comme vous le disiez, la rentrée scolaire est un petit peu avancée, la fin de l'année scolaire est un petit peu reculée.
Pourquoi est-ce que c'était important, cette réforme ?
Ben donc, je vous disais tout à l'heure, d'abord, c'est une réforme qui est dans les cartons depuis trente ans. Ça, c'est quand même rare.
Il faut quand même le souligner. Donc il y a trente ans, les premiers chronobiologistes ont commencé à s'intéresser à cette histoire de rythme scolaire.
Et en fait, ben, ça fait— c'est comme tout le reste, hein, ça fait partie de notre culture, de notre paysage.
On a toujours eu des rythmes comme ça. Et pourquoi est-ce qu'on changerait tout ça ? Mais en fait, simplement parce que ces rythmes scolaires, au départ, ils sont basés sur les besoins d'organisation du travail des adultes,
puisqu'au départ, on a des très longues vacances d'été parce que les enfants, ils allaient aider aux moissons leurs parents.
Donc c'est ça l'idée de départ. C'est pour ça qu'on a deux mois de vacances en été. Et donc c'est ça qui détermine aussi toute l'organisation de notre calendrier scolaire, ce qui est un peu bizarre aujourd'hui.
Et donc l'idée de cette réforme, c'est de se dire, on pourrait faire mieux tout en gardant strictement le même nombre de jours d'école et le même nombre de jours de congé.
On a toujours cent quatre-vingt-deux jours d'école par an. Ce qu'on a voulu faire, c'est organiser une meilleure régularité sur toute l'année scolaire.
Et donc, le rythme idéal décrit par les experts en chronobiologie, c'est de se dire, on fait sept semaines de travail et deux semaines de congé.
Ça, c'est le bon rythme pour que l'organisme se repose, se régénère, etc. et qu'on reparte chaque fois sur des bonnes bases, sur un nouveau cycle.
Pour ça, et pour avoir cette régularité la plus parfaite possible, on doit effectivement un peu raccourcir les vacances d'été.
Ce qui n'est pas plus mal non plus. Parce qu'en fait, deux mois de vacances, c'est même souvent en fait neuf semaines sans école, sans contact avec l'école.
C'est en fait une période très très longue, ce qui pose toute une série de problèmes d'organisation pour les familles, hein, parce que même ceux qui ont la chance de partir en vacances, en général, ils partent deux semaines.
Ça laisse quand même sept semaines d'organisation, des parents qui travaillent, des gosses qu'il faut mettre en stage, etc., c'est pas évident.
Mais en plus pour les enfants, et principalement de nouveau pour les enfants les plus défavorisés, ceux qui parlent pas français à la maison, des choses comme ça.
Mais en fait, une rupture des liens avec l'école pendant neuf semaines, c'est un peu catastrophique parce qu'ils reviennent en septembre, en ayant régressé par rapport à leur niveau de juin.
Et donc, chaque année, les enseignants témoignent de ça. Le mois de septembre est un mois de remise à niveau, quoi. On doit aller rechercher vraiment une série d'élèves.
Et donc l'idée de réduire un peu répond aussi à cette problématique-là. Après, on a aussi des chiffres, hein, qui viennent étayer ça.
Par exemple, entre Toussaint et mars— C'est vraiment une période un peu cruciale quoi, où on a cette petite semaine de Toussaint maintenant qui permet pas de recharger suffisamment les batteries.
Ça aussi, c'est expliqué par les chronobiologistes. Ils disent : En fait, en une semaine, le corps a à peine le temps de comprendre qu'on est en vacances, qu'on redémarre et on n'est pas reposé en fait.
Et du coup, ben l'effet, il est direct. Les enseignants et les élèves, ils tombent malades beaucoup plus que les autres parties de l'année.
On a un taux d'absentéisme qui flambe entre novembre et mars. C'est extrêmement compliqué pour les remplacements, etc. Et donc—
Entre novembre et mars ?
Ouais. Tout l'hiver en fait.
La plupart du temps en fait.
Oui, oui. Mais donc c'est quand même édifiant. Et alors, on a pu le mesurer, c'est un peu étrange, c'est un des effets bizarres de la crise, mais je sais pas si vous vous souvenez, en novembre 2020, on a dû,
contraints par un pic épidémique, on a dû faire deux semaines à Toussaint.
Et on a vu en fait le taux d'absentéisme vraiment chuter par rapport aux autres années.
C'est un contexte particulier, mais j'entends bien que—
Mais donc voilà, c'était intéressant. Après, ça n'a pas une validité scientifique.
Face à cette réforme, il y a une série, encore une fois, de— nouveau bouclier. Est-ce que vous avez entendu les arguments ou bien est-ce que c'est à nouveau juste le fameux conservatisme, le on ne touche pas à mes congés scolaires ?
Non, il y a une partie des arguments, évidemment, que j'entends, parce que finalement, sur le fond de la réforme, il y a assez peu de contestations.
Parce qu'on l'a expliqué en disant : on part des besoins de l'élève. C'est la première fois qu'une réforme est tout à fait basée sur les besoins de l'enfant.
Par contre, ce qui a été fort contesté, et ça, je le comprends, c'est qu'on avance en Communauté française sans attendre les autres communautés.
Oui oui, tout à fait.
Et ça, ça pose une série de problèmes.
Vous avez d'ailleurs dit qu'on pouvait postposer la réforme si les autres avançaient plus vite.
Alors, on a mené depuis le début, évidemment, des consultations avec les autres communautés.
La difficulté principale, je dirais, c'est que nous, c'était inscrit dans notre accord politique, dans notre accord de gouvernement.
C'était pas le cas des Flamands et des Germanophones. Donc quand je suis arrivée avec cette demande, ils me disent : Nous, c'est pas prévu comme ça, etc.
On était en sortie de crise COVID, donc pour eux, c'est quand même un très très gros changement sociétal que nous, on avait préparé.
Vous savez, ma prédécesseure, Marie-Martine Schyns, elle avait commandé une étude de faisabilité à la Fondation Roi Baudouin.
Quand moi, je suis arrivée à l'éducation, j'avais sur ma table un rapport déjà expliquant comment il fallait mener cette réforme.
C'était dans notre accord de majorité. On a mené toutes les concertations nécessaires avec l'ensemble des secteurs concernés, tourisme, économie, les transports en commun, publics.
C'est une réforme qui touche beaucoup beaucoup de monde quoi. Donc c'était important vraiment qu'on mène ces concertations.
On a fait tout ça. Et puis évidemment, on est entrés en dialogue avec les autres communautés. Mais à un moment, ils disent : Ben, on va y réfléchir.
Ils ont aussi des experts qui plaident plutôt disant : En fait, c'est les francophones qui ont raison, c'est ça qu'il faut faire.
Mais ils ont fait leur consultation avec leurs syndicats. Les Flamands ont dit : Ben pour nous, c'est pas mûr, c'est pas le moment.
On n'a pas encore eu le temps de faire toutes les consultations, etc. Et donc, il nous reste deux ans de législature. Ça va pas se passer en deux ans, c'est clair.
Donc, ça va être sans doute l'objet d'un prochain accord de gouvernement chez eux. Et donc moi—
Est-ce que vous ne faites que l'espérer ou bien est-ce que vous avez vraiment le sentiment que ça a l'air de se profiler comme ça ?
Ben, je vous dis, nous, on est convaincus du bien-fondé de la réforme. On n'est pas les seuls. C'est pas une lubie francophone.
Il y a des experts flamands qui poussent en ce sens-là. Il y a des politiciens flamands qui poussent en ce sens-là aussi.
Donc, je crois que le débat va continuer à vivre. Maintenant, il faut juste bien comprendre que notre enseignement est communautarisé.
Et donc moi, je peux discuter avec mes collègues, mais objectivement, j'ai pas à leur imposer ni ce qu'ils doivent faire, ni l'agenda de leur réforme.
Et donc, c'est un peu la limite de nos moyens d'action. Et donc c'est ce que j'ai expliqué au Parlement. J'ai dit : Écoutez, voilà, nous, notre réforme est prête, on a fait les concertations qu'il faut, etc.
Soit on attend les autres, alors qu'on n'a aucune garantie qu'un jour, ils vont embrayer finalement. Donc moi, je le crois, mais voilà, on y va.
Et donc on a décidé, avec une majorité au Parlement, d'y aller. Alors c'est vrai que ça pose une série de problèmes, notamment pour les familles qui ont des enfants dans deux systèmes scolaires différents.
C'est le cas pour certains Bruxellois. Ça, je réponds : Écoutez, sur quatorze à quinze semaines de congés sur une année scolaire, il y en a encore dix à onze qui sont complètement communes.
Donc la majorité des vacances d'été, souvent une semaine à Toussaint ou à Carnaval, et les vacances de Noël qui sont complètement communes.
Donc ça, voilà, il y a Pâques qui va être très différent. Ça nécessite des aménagements, évidemment, des habitudes de chacun.
C'est pas évident, mais voilà, la question, c'était vraiment dans un contexte où l'enseignement est communautarisé, est-ce qu'on a le droit de mener une réforme dont on est convaincu qu'elle est faite pour le bien-être des enfants, oui ou non ?
Voilà, on a décidé que oui.
Alors, parlons maintenant du fameux tronc commun, donc réforme centrale du Pacte pour un enseignement d'excellence, donc qui va, vous l'avez dit, impacter à ce stade uniquement les premières et deuxièmes primaires.
Oui.
Pas encore les autres. Donc l'idée, corrigez-moi si j'ai mal compris. L'idée, c'est que, au final, quand ces élèves-là, donc les élèves de la— qui sont nés en,
il y a six, sept ans, c'est-à-dire en 2015, 2014, à peu près.
Donc ces élèves-là, une fois, ne pourront plus être spécialisés dans un enseignement technique ou professionnel jusqu'à l'âge de—
Quinze ans.
Quinze ans, oui, c'est ça. Leur programme scolaire va être repensé. Il y a l'idée d'accentuer, de bien bien former sur les bases, bien bien serrer la vis au début de l'enseignement.
Il y aura l'idée, au début des secondaires, de parler de numérique. Je ne sais pas si c'est toujours le cas, mais on avait parlé de faire beaucoup de latin au début des secondaires.
C'est toujours prévu, ça ?
Pas beaucoup de latin, mais du latin.
Plus de latin qu'auparavant.
Deux heures de latin, mais ce qui a— la différence, c'est que ce sera pour tout le monde.
Ok ok, j'avais retenu que c'était quatre heures.
Non, c'est deux heures en complément du cours de français, en fait.
Ok ok. Qu'est-ce que j'ai oublié dans cette—
Non, je pense que c'est un bon résumé. Peut-être juste revenir... À la base quoi, pourquoi est-ce qu'on veut un tronc commun ?
Je disais tout à l'heure, on a des systèmes scolaires qui fonctionnent de manière beaucoup plus inclusive et qui sont plus égalitaires que le nôtre.
Or, on sait qu'un de nos gros problèmes, c'est qu'on a un système très inégalitaire. Donc c'est une réponse à ça. Et donc, l'idée, c'est vraiment de se dire, on recrée, recompose un parcours d'apprentissage
renforcé et commun à tous les élèves, depuis les maternelles, jusqu'à la troisième secondaire.
Donc le but, c'est vraiment qu'à quinze ans, tout le monde soit doté d'un bagage commun suffisant pour devenir un citoyen, s'insérer dans la société, etc.
Mais aussi, pour être progressivement amené,
à poser des choix, des choix positifs d'orientation. C'est vraiment un des volets peut-être dont vous n'avez pas parlé, mais qui est très présent dans ce tronc commun.
C'est l'idée de— que les élèves doivent aussi,
parce qu'ils ont des intelligences multiples, différentes,
doivent aussi apprendre à se connaître, à connaître leurs forces et leurs faiblesses et doivent être amenés, à la fin de la troisième secondaire, à pouvoir poser des choix positifs pour la suite de leur parcours.
Puisque c'est à ce moment-là, effectivement seulement, à partir de la quatrième, qu'ils décideront s'ils poursuivent dans l'enseignement, on va dire général de transition ou s'ils s'orientent vers de l'enseignement qualifiant.
On veut aussi vraiment redorer l'image de l'enseignement qualifiant.
Mh.
C'est un enseignement dont on a besoin, qui mène à des métiers d'avenir qu'on ne connaît même pas encore dans leur entièreté d'ailleurs, mais qui seront très nécessaires dans les prochaines années.
Et aujourd'hui, malheureusement, on sait que cet enseignement qualifiant est un enseignement de relégation où les élèves arrivent, je caricature un peu, mais quand ils ont échoué leur CE1D et qu'ils sont poussés par là.
Un verdict A ou B ou...
C'est ça, exactement. Et donc le CE1D, malheureusement, agit un peu comme une gare de triage, en fait. Et donc...
Mh.
Les élèves ne sont pas dans un système qualifiant...
CE1D qui est donc l'examen qu'on reçoit...
En deuxième secondaire. Oui, c'est un peu le CEB des deuxièmes secondaires. Et donc, c'est ça qu'on veut changer. Et pour ça,
ben, ça nécessite aussi que ce tronc commun, il soit polytechnique, c'est-à-dire qu'on puisse justement davantage mobiliser différentes formes d'intelligence, permettre aux enfants déjà de toucher...
Il y a une toute nouvelle formation manuelle, technique, technologique et numérique dans le programme du tronc commun.
Justement parce que comment est-ce qu'on peut demander à un élève de faire un choix positif vers l'enseignement qualifiant s'il n'a jamais touché à des matières techniques pendant tout le début de sa scolarité ?
C'est compliqué. Et donc voilà, l'idée, c'est ça, que progressivement, au fur et à mesure de ce parcours du tronc commun, l'élève ait appris à se connaître.
Surtout, les dernières années seront vraiment beaucoup plus orientantes. On va prévoir des semaines de stage, de découverte des métiers, etc.
L'idée, c'est vraiment aussi de, voilà, d'ouvrir le champ, les horizons pour les élèves et de leur permettre...
C'est quand même un pan, en fait, qui est assez fort négligé, l'orientation. Ben, les CPMS travaillent un peu en général avec les rétros à la toute fin d'un parcours, mais ce n'est pas quelque chose qu'on mature, en fait.
Et ça, ça fait défaut. Et donc ce nouveau tronc commun, c'est huit domaines d'apprentissage avec des nouveautés totales.
C'est neuf référentiels différents qui ont été travaillés, je disais, par des experts pendant quatre ans, qui sont beaucoup plus touffus et précis que les anciens socles de compétences.
On a vraiment été chercher année par année ce qu'on doit savoir absolument. Tout ça sera décliné ensuite en programmes par les réseaux d'enseignement.
Et ce qui est intéressant aussi, c'est que pour chaque année d'enseignement, ils situent les apprentissages de l'année en question, mais aussi, ben, qu'est-ce qui était attendu l'année d'avant et qu'est-ce qui sera attendu l'année d'après.
Donc, ça permet aussi à l'enseignant de bien se situer par rapport à ses collègues en amont et en aval. Et donc,
voilà, une série d'innovations, des matières complètement nouvelles, l'éducation culturelle et artistique, la formation manuelle, technique, technologique et numérique dont je parlais,
des nouveaux domaines comme l'esprit d'entreprendre, la créativité,
tout ce qui était lié à l'orientation.
Donc voilà, il y a beaucoup de choses. On a vraiment essayé, avec ce tronc commun, de répondre à la fois au sens de l'école dont on parlait tout à l'heure, aux enjeux très modernes du vingt-et-unième siècle.
Alors ça amène de très nombreuses questions. Déjà, de nouveaux piliers qui apparaissent, de nouveaux socles de compétences, comme vous le disiez.
Qu'est-ce qui disparaît alors ?
Ben, c'est un exercice d'équilibriste.
Oui, bien sûr.
Et notamment, on va devoir en permanence évaluer la soutenabilité de tout ça. Parce que...
Ah oui, OK.
Ah oui, c'est vraiment dans ce sens-là.
On peut plus suivre en avançant, oui.
Les référentiels sont votés maintenant au Parlement.
Oui, oui.
Mais pour vous donner un exemple, il y avait un groupe de travail sur le référentiel des sciences humaines qui contient la géo, l'histoire, les sciences sociales, qui sont aussi une nouvelle matière, les sciences économiques.
Vous savez, on était autant d'experts autour de la table. Chacun a l'impression que sa discipline est absolument essentielle pour les élèves à quinze ans.
C'est compliqué. Il faut faire des arbitrages en permanence. Et donc c'est pour ça que ça a mis quasiment quatre ans de travail.
C'est pas évident. En plus, il y a parfois un peu d'idéologie derrière sur ce qui est essentiel après l'école.
J'allais le dire, oui.
C'était pas du tout un travail facile qui a été... On avait une commission des référentiels qui était chargée d'arbitrer tout ça.
Ça a été, après, je vous le disais, voté au Parlement. Donc, on a cherché le consensus le plus fort, parce que c'est pas rien, en fait, de définir ce qu'on est censé connaître à l'école.
Il faut un consensus avec la société pour être encore bien raccord avec les enjeux. Mais en même temps, c'est un défi complètement passionnant.
Donc, on va faire ce travail d'évaluation au fur et à mesure pour vérifier que tout ça est bien soutenable sur le terrain, même si on a essayé d'élaguer au maximum pour que ça reste le cas.
J'ai pas d'exemple comme ça de ce qui n'existe plus du tout, mais il y a...
Plus du tout, non, mais qu'est-ce qui va être réduit ? Qu'est-ce qui va baisser en importance ? Est-ce que... Bon, je...
Comme vous le disiez tout à l'heure, on a vraiment recentré les premières années sur les savoirs de base. Très très important de maîtriser convenablement un savoir de base.
Je donne un exemple, mais si on maîtrise pas convenablement la lecture, on est handicapé toute sa scolarité pour comprendre des énoncés, etc.
Donc ça, c'est vraiment le point de départ. Après, il y a pas des choses qu'on... Enfin, on n'a pas décidé de plus faire de mathématiques ou d'en faire moins dans le reste de la scolarité.
Mais par exemple, introduire des éléments de formation numérique, ça nous semble aujourd'hui assez nécessaire.
On va en parler, on va en parler.
Ben, je peux pas vous dire qu'est-ce qu'on a supprimé. C'est des rééquilibrages, c'est subtil parce que...
On a beaucoup de mal à comprendre comment on peut rajouter toutes ces, voilà, sociologie, esprit d'entreprendre, numérique, etc.
Oui, mais tout ne se fait pas à partir de la première primaire.
Non, non, non, non. Je ne parlais pas spécifiquement de la première. Là, je parle du tronc commun de A à Z, même si, comme vous le disiez, ça reste encore à définir pour les années suivantes.
OK, mais donc je vois que ça reste encore un petit peu flou.
Oui, parce que c'est des rééquilibrages un peu subtils, c'est des questions d'une période à l'autre. Il faut aller voir les grilles horaires que je connais évidemment pas par cœur.
Mais voilà. Donc, en tout cas, on n'a rien sacrifié, évidemment, d'essentiel, mais il y a plein d'adaptations. Pour prendre un cours dont on parle peu et qui pourtant est important, l'éducation physique.
Ben, on a ajouté tout un volet éducation à la santé. Et donc, les professeurs d'éducation physique, ils vont avoir quand même tout un volet, pensons, premiers secours, nutrition.
Enfin, tout ça, c'est des choses qui vont apparaître, en fait, dans le cursus, mais qui vont faire partie intégrante du cours de gym, comme on l'appelait, mais qui va aujourd'hui avoir beaucoup plus de corps.
C'est un exemple qu'on ne cite jamais, mais j'en profite.
OK, mais je vais vous tendre une perche puisque c'est un élément qu'on entend parfois, souvent, au sein du Parti socialiste.
C'est une certaine frustration par rapport à l'importance du cours de religion dans l'enseignement libre, qu'on voudrait peut-être voir réduire en importance au profit du cours de philosophie et citoyenneté.
Est-ce que ça, c'est un élément important au sein du tronc commun ?
Alors, ben, il y a un référentiel d'éducation à la philosophie et citoyenneté. Il se fait que le référentiel précédent était un peu parmi les plus jeunes puisque c'était un cours encore assez nouveau.
Je dirais que, ben, le cours de philo et citoyenneté, il a le mérite maintenant d'exister dans l'enseignement officiel.
Il est, on va dire, dilué dans d'autres cours dans l'enseignement libre. C'est pas une situation idéale.
Très clairement, je pense que...
Mais vous êtes ministre et vous émettez du regret par rapport à cette situation. Est-ce que vous n'êtes pas en...
C'était sans doute un des sujets les plus sensibles de la législature précédente. C'était un compromis à la belge, on va dire,
et qui... Et c'est un dossier qui est pas fini, qui est en... Je sais pas si vous l'avez suivi, mais on... Il y a une résolution qui a été approuvée par le Parlement,
pour porter le cours de philosophie et citoyenneté à deux heures dans l'enseignement officiel.
On est en train de travailler sur les conclusions de ceci parce que, voilà, le cours, il a le mérite d'exister, les référentiels sont là.
Franchement, c'est un cours qui est très très important, je pense aujourd'hui, mais qui, avec une heure, limité dans ses moyens et puis qui pose des questions d'organisation interne.
Et par ailleurs, l'organisation du cours de religion, il pose toute une série de problèmes, ne fût-ce qu'organisationnels.
Moi, personnellement, j'aime pas de toute façon l'idée qu'on sépare les élèves en fonction de leurs convictions.
Mais en plus, aujourd'hui, ça pose des problèmes d'organisation terribles dans les établissements, quoi. Des profs qui doivent faire,
je sais pas combien d'établissements avec les trajets qui s'ensuivent, l'organisation des classes qui est rendue quasiment comme un casse-tête impossible.
Alors, la question se pose moins dans l'enseignement libre où ils n'organisent que le cours de religion catholique, évidemment.
C'est ça le... Mais dans l'enseignement officiel, c'est extrêmement compliqué.
Ça ne veut pas bouger, ça ? Pas l'idée d'introduire le cours de...
Ben, vous savez que pour tout à fait bouleverser cette organisation-là, il faudrait changer la Constitution, ce qui n'est pas une mince affaire.
Donc ça, c'est une réponse. Et voilà, moi, j'ai pas non plus pour ambition de rouvrir fondamentalement la guerre scolaire.
C'est pas d'ailleurs dans ma feuille de route, c'est sensible. Mais faire évoluer le cours de philo et citoyenneté, ça, c'est effectivement bien à l'ordre du jour.
OK. Donc, vous avez aussi évoqué la question des sciences et technologies dans le cadre de ce tronc commun.
Est-ce que les élèves vont enfin apprendre à coder ? Est-ce que c'est prévu ? Est-ce que...
Tout à fait.
À quel niveau ? Est-ce que...
C'est prévu, si je ne me trompe pas, en deuxième secondaire. Alors, c'est les bases de la programmation, du codage, etc.
Mais il y aura effectivement enfin quelque chose de prévu à ce niveau-là.
Oui, ce sera dans six ans alors.
Voilà. Ça, c'est la difficulté du choix qu'on a fait, mais on fait entrer le tronc commun. Voilà. Non, mais ce qui est compliqué, c'est qu'on peut pas
envoyer une réforme comme ça dans toutes les années en même temps parce que derrière, il y a un défi en matière de formation des enseignants qui est énorme.
Et donc quand on fait entrer en vigueur le tronc commun pour les premières et deuxièmes primaires, on doit former tous les enseignants concernés par ces années-là.
Donc c'est, de mémoire, douze mille enseignants, quelque chose comme ça. Et puis on va faire la même chose avec les troisièmes, quatrièmes primaires et puis on va monter une année après l'autre.
Alors, parfois, c'est frustrant parce qu'on voudrait aller plus vite, mais bon, j'ai appris quand même qu'il faut être un peu raisonnable.
Ça me paraît sensé, ouais. Mais c'était tout le sujet de mon interview avec Alexander De Croo il y a quatre ans.
Qu'est-ce qui vous a amenée à prendre cette décision d'introduire la programmation à l'école ? Est-ce qu'il y a eu un lobbying ?
Est-ce que c'était une conviction personnelle ?
Non. D'abord, c'est pas moi qui ai décidé. De nouveau, tout ça a été décidé dans les groupes de travail sur les référentiels, mais je pense que c'est aujourd'hui une évidence...
Que, en fait, on voit bien, ben, les élèves, on a l'impression qu'ils gèrent les...
qu'ils gèrent les...
Oui, c'est une illusion ensemble.
Les outils numériques parce qu'ils sont tous avec des smartphones.
Sur TikTok.
On a encore vu
pendant la crise sanitaire, quand on a dû passer à l'enseignement à distance, à quel point ils maîtrisent rien quand il s'agit de vraiment utiliser un ordinateur, ne fût-ce que,
pour utiliser une plateforme ou envoyer un mail à leur professeur.
Donc ils ont un usage numérique assez particulier, les adolescents. Et donc, ben, l'idée de pouvoir
comprendre les bases effectivement du codage, de la programmation, c'est aussi leur donner des compétences numériques qu'ils n'ont pas aujourd'hui.
Et donc ça, ça semblait être une évidence. Pour autant, on a un discours assez, on va dire, nuancé sur le numérique à l'école.
Aujourd'hui, c'est évidemment incontournable et ça offre des potentialités, ne fût-ce qu'en termes de ressources pour les enseignants, de...
De pédagogie.
De formation, de pédagogie. Donc on doit évidemment s'emparer de tout ça. Et d'un autre côté, on voit aussi les limites du tout numérique.
Enfin nous, on l'a expérimenté pendant la crise sanitaire avec l'enseignement à distance. Objectivement, on a besoin de relationnel.
Le métier d'enseignant, on ne peut pas s'imaginer dans une relation purement à distance, ça marche pas. Je veux dire, ça, on en a eu la démonstration très claire.
Donc tout l'enjeu aujourd'hui, c'est de revoir notre stratégie numérique qui préexistait à la crise,
en gardant tout ce que les écoles ont fait comme progrès en matière numérique, parce qu'il y a eu un vrai saut qualitatif partout et en même temps en se disant on est quand même heureux de pouvoir,
renouer des relations humaines dans le cadre pédagogique.
Un autre exemple que vous avez évoqué donc dans le cadre des sciences sociales, c'est, un peu de sociologie, un peu de socio...
Oui, tout à fait.
Dans l'école secondaire. À quoi ça ressemble ?
Ça, ça a été vraiment le nerf de la guerre dans les référentiels. Beaucoup, beaucoup de disputes entre experts sur ces sujets, parce que...
Oui parce qu'on ne peut pas cette...
C'est hautement idéologique quand même, en fait.
Ouais, tout à fait, ouais.
Mais oui, il y aura effectivement un peu de sciences humaines. Alors il y a aussi le fait qu'on ne s'est pas encore attaqué au référentiel de l'après tronc commun.
Et donc, il y a aussi beaucoup d'experts qui voulaient mettre énormément de choses. Et de temps en temps, on a dû leur rappeler attention, ici, on est dans un tronc commun jusqu'à quinze ans.
On ne peut plus trop parler de tronc, ouais, ouais.
Il y a encore des choses qui vont se faire en quatrième, cinquième rétro et il y a quand même toujours cette logique spiralaire où on peut repasser sur des choses et les approfondir au fur et à mesure.
Et donc tout ne peut pas être envisagé. Mais on est quand même,
enfin, moi en tout cas, je suis très très
heureuse et fière que soit inscrit dans ces nouveaux référentiels, par exemple, qu'on soit obligé de parler de l'histoire du colonialisme, qu'on soit obligé de parler de l'histoire de la Shoah déjà dans le tronc commun, même si on y reviendra...
Et comme c'est une étrange énigme, j'en parlais avec Dan Gagnon qui donc,
Belge, mais né au Canada, très surpris de voir à quel point les Belges ne sont pas formés du tout sur les questions du colonialisme, de Léopold II, etc.
Ouais.
Juste une parenthèse là-dessus avant de continuer sur la suite. Mais comment est-ce que vous expliquez ça ?
Ben, je pense que comme...
Ça va changer, mais pourquoi...
Oui, oui, que comme plein d'autres pays, ben quand l'histoire est encore un peu récente, parfois, on a des difficultés à l'aborder.
Ouais.
Moi, je fais partie d'une génération où on parlait absolument pas du Congo.
Non, on parlait pas.
Donc, alors aujourd'hui, je serais plus nuancée que ça parce qu'il y a quand même des écoles qui l'abordent et des professeurs d'histoire qui l'abordent très très bien.
Il y a des programmes aussi de certains réseaux qui l'abordent, mais simplement...
C'est sur base d'initiatives...
On voudrait que ce soit généralisé. Voilà.
C'est sur base d'initiatives personnelles.
Exactement.
Ouais.
Et donc, il est temps de changer ça et je pense que ça se fait en parallèle avec aussi un contexte, la société où on sent que le débat est plus mûr, quoi.
On a eu beaucoup de la société civile qui a agi sur la question. On voit, ben, même le discours du roi qui est en train d'évoluer.
On voit tout le travail qui est mené par Thomas Dermine sur la restitution. Voilà, il y a tout le travail sur les enfants métis.
Donc il y a une série de choses qui sont en cours de route et je pense que du coup, ben, les temps sont vraiment mûrs pour se dire ça fait partie de l'histoire de notre pays et on doit pouvoir la regarder en face.
Il y a tout le travail qui a été fait à la Chambre aussi avec les experts, qui est quand même pas tendre sur le rôle de l'État belge au Congo.
Donc voilà, je crois qu'aujourd'hui les esprits sont mûrs simplement pour enseigner ça de manière,
la plus objective possible et de prendre aussi notre part de responsabilité dans les atrocités qui ont été commises par le Congo belge.
Excellent, mais on va suivre ça avec attention. Un autre point, dans le cadre de cette réforme pour ce pacte, pour l'enseignement d'excellence, c'est la question des inégalités liées au genre.
Donc une attention, d'après les documents que j'ai pu me procurer, une attention particulière en ce qui concerne la formation et une attention particulière en ce qui concerne les,
donc les inégalités liées au genre, je le disais, qu'est-ce que ça signifie concrètement ?
Est-ce que les professeurs vont devenir moins machos qu'auparavant ? Qu'est-ce que—
Ben, de nouveau, j'ai un peu tendance à me dire que l'école doit vraiment au minimum suivre les évolutions sociétales, mais peut-être parfois même un peu les anticiper—
C'est le minimum
Dans l'idéal, voilà. Et voilà, de nouveau, ce sont des débats qui sont hyper présents dans la société. On voit que les jeunes sont quand même vraiment très très concernés par les questions liées au genre,
à l'égalité des genres, mais aussi aux questions d'identité.
Et donc, ce sont des préoccupations qu'on a intégrées dans le cadre des référentiels du tronc commun, dans différents référentiels, lutte contre les stéréotypes de genre, etc.
Donc ça, ça fait partie vraiment des contenus de différents cours. Mais à côté de ça, il y a tout le travail qui est fait sur ce qu'on appelle les EVRAS, donc l'éducation à la vie affective, relationnelle et sexuelle. Le contraire.
Ouais, c'est ça, oui.
C'est toujours difficile les acronymes.
Non, il y a pas de souci.
Et dans l'enseignement, il y en a beaucoup. Mais donc, là-dessus, il y a une vraie volonté politique d'avancer parce que l'EVRAS, il est censé être généralisé dans toutes les écoles et on voit que c'est pas suffisamment le cas
en fonction des réseaux, en fonction des types d'enseignement, etc.
C'est à géométrie très variable. Donc il y a une volonté politique forte d'avancer avec mes collègues Christine Morreale et Barbara Trachte pour la Wallonie pour Bruxelles.
Donc on a activé toute la plateforme EVRAS pour à la fois,
définir des contenus. Donc en plus des référentiels, on va vraiment faire un document annexe thématique lié à l'EVRAS qui pourra être mobilisé par les enseignants qui souhaitent faire des choses spécifiques sur ces questions.
Et alors ce qu'on voudrait faire, c'est rendre obligatoire dans le cursus des moments où il doit y avoir des animations EVRAS obligatoirement, je vais inventer ici, mais par exemple en sixième primaire, deuxième secondaire, etc.
À différents moments clés de la scolarité qui soient alors assurés par des opérateurs agréés type plannings familiaux, etc.
Bon, c'est une question essentielle, tout à fait. Mais c'est pas exactement la question donc des inégalités aux genres.
Je vais prendre un exemple très très concret. On parlait d'initiation au numérique.
Oui.
Il y avait déjà un tout petit peu de numérique, par exemple dans les maths huit en fin de secondaire. Et là on pouvait observer des situations parfois de type de
Oh, mademoiselle, pour vous, pas besoin de faire l'exercice de programmation, ça va peut-être un peu trop dur, ne vous inquiétez pas etc.
Donc des stéréotypes bien ancrés—
Oui. Et parfois complètement inconscients.
Oui, tout à fait, souvent. Et donc ce qu'on appelle une forme de sexisme entre gros guillemets, bienveillant. Ce genre de truc-là, donc formation initiale qui va aborder ces questions—
Et formation continue.
Formation continue qui va aussi aborder ces questions. Mais encore une fois, c'est vraiment, dans ce cas-là, très fort imbibé d'idéologie.
Donc il y a déjà une série de formations à l'Institut de formation professionnelle continue, pour les enseignants,
justement pour déconstruire parce que les stéréotypes de ce type-là,
bon ici, il est peut-être un peu gros pour qu'on puisse penser que ce soit inconscient, mais il y a des choses qui sont encore beaucoup plus, beaucoup plus masquées, beaucoup plus subtiles,
beaucoup plus profondément ancrées.
La façon d'interroger les élèves même. Enfin, il y a parfois vraiment des choses... Bon, je vous parle même pas des jeux genrés, etc.
dans les classes de maternelle. Enfin, il y a encore énormément de travail. Et donc oui, il y a un gros boulot en formation
continue pour ma part, parce que formation initiale, c'est chez ma collègue Valérie Glatigny, mais évidemment, elle s'occupe de ça aussi.
Il y a tout ce qui est encouragement des jeunes filles à s'engager dans les filières STEM parce qu'on voit un défi.
Il continue à y avoir trop peu de jeunes filles qui s'engagent dans les métiers des sciences et même dans les études scientifiques.
Donc il y a tout ce boulot-là qui est fait au travers des journées de sensibilisation, etc.
On a, dans le style plus basique, mais qui est quand même aussi important, on vient de faire un appel à projets pour les primaires sur l'aménagement des cours de récré.
Alors c'est un peu basique, c'est un peu la base, mais en même temps c'est très très important parce qu'on voit, pour caricaturer un peu, dans beaucoup de cours de récré,
tout l'espace qui est censé être commun, qui est vraiment monopolisé par un terrain de foot improvisé pour les garçons, que les filles sont exclues.
Donc on a ici proposé d'accompagner les écoles primaires qui le souhaitent pour repenser l'organisation dans l'espace et dans le partage de l'espace commun des cours.
Il y a toute la formation des équipes
du secondaire sur les problématiques liées au genre et aux stéréotypes de genre, un peu liées à la problématique des tenues vestimentaires qui revient comme un marronnier un peu chaque été.
Comment aborder ça dans les règlements d'ordre intérieur ? Comment les concerter avec les élèves pour que la norme soit mieux comprise et partagée ?
Enfin, comment échanger les représentations autour de ça ? C'est vraiment des débats qui sont importants,
pour lesquels aujourd'hui, je pense que les équipes sont plutôt demandeuses d'être un peu soutenues, parce que objectivement, c'est pas si évident.
Et donc là, on va avoir un guide qui va sortir à la rentrée rien que sur cette question. Alors, on a des questions peut-être un peu plus annexes, mais qui sont quand même bien prégnantes aujourd'hui.
On a initié un travail avec l'ASBL Trans Kids, pour ce qui concerne les enfants transgenres qui, là aussi, des écoles sont parfois un peu—
J'imagine, bien, oui.
Oui, bien démunies par rapport à l'accueil des enfants transgenres. Donc, on est en train d'identifier
tous les barrages quelque part à l'intégration de ce type d'enfants, toutes les assignations aux genres qui sont parfois des vêtements, des formulaires, le prénom, les cours de gymnastique.
Faut choisir fille, garçon, les toilettes. Enfin, toutes ces questions qui en fait sont là. Je crois que le mouvement est en marche.
On est face à une génération de féministes assez engagées et très jeunes. Je veux dire, je repense aux questions liées aux tenues vestimentaires.
Voilà, les jeunes filles ont décidé de ne pas se laisser faire sur ces questions et elles sont très très—
Mais justement,
si on prend un exemple concret d'un professeur qui se comporterait de manière, qui porterait encore ces stéréotypes et ce sexisme conscient ou inconscient, est-ce qu'elles sont obligées de se laisser faire ?
Est-ce qu'elles peuvent hausser la voix, hausser le ton ?
Bien sûr, et ben, on encourage. C'est un autre volet qui me tient fort à cœur. C'est tout ce qui concerne la démocratie scolaire et quelque part la justice scolaire, qui sont au cœur du climat scolaire dans les écoles.
Donc c'est vraiment des enjeux qui sont importants. On voit bien que dans des écoles où le climat scolaire est serein, apaisé, en général, il y a une démocratie scolaire vivace quoi.
Ça veut dire que les élèves sont pleinement acteurs de cette microsociété qu'est l'école et qui doivent s'investir et porter des projets, défendre leurs idées, etc.
Et plus le cadre est, je dirais, bien installé, réglementé, plus ça marche bien quoi. D'où l'idée de réintégrer cette question, par exemple,
des tenues vestimentaires dans une réflexion plus générale sur le rôle et le fonctionnement des organes représentatifs dans les écoles quoi.
C'est important qu'il y ait des conseils de classe, des conseils d'école, des délégués d'élèves, un conseil de participation qui fonctionne parce que c'est des lieux de dialogue et de concertation quoi.
De nouveau, je reviens sur la question des règlements de l'ordre intérieur des écoles qui sont quand même au cœur du fonctionnement de cette microsociété qu'est l'école.
Mais plus ils sont co-construits, plus ils sont respectés facilement quoi, de nouveau. Et si on reprend l'exemple des tenues, ben, il faut échanger les représentations quoi.
Pourquoi est-ce qu'un professeur trouve qu'un crop top, c'est pas une tenue adaptée pour aller à l'école ? Pourquoi est-ce qu'une jeune fille trouve qu'elle a le droit d'aller comme ça ?
À un moment, il faut qu'ils dialoguent autour de ça quoi. Avec, est-ce qu'on peut aller tout nu à l'école ?
C'est difficile de dialoguer quand il y a un rapport de pouvoir, quand il y a une hiérarchie.
Non, c'est pour ça qu'il faut que ce soit bien organisé, c'est-à-dire qu'il y ait un cadre...
Non, je pense vraiment, c'est dans l'intérêt des établissements et je pense que ceux qui le pratiquent en sont très très convaincus en fait quoi.
Que plus le cadre est négocié, plus il est admis de part et d'autre et mieux ça se passe après quoi. Je pense que tous les élèves, même les plus,
les plus acharnés défenseurs de la liberté de s'habiller n'importe comment à l'école, pourront être d'accord, dire on peut pas aller tout nu à l'école.
Est-ce que c'est si grave qu'un élève ait les cheveux bleus, pour prendre un exemple. Voilà, c'est comme toute vie en société quoi.
Il faut un cadre de vie commun, et voilà, pour qu'il soit respecté, je pense qu'il faut que chacun puisse comprendre les arguments de l'autre et ce qu'il y a dans la tête de l'autre.
Oui. Alors, deux questions qu'on n'a pas encore abordées avant de se quitter. La question du harcèlement scolaire et la question de la mixité sociale.
J'ai cru comprendre, mais évidemment, ça fait une dizaine d'années que je ne suis plus à l'école, j'ai cru comprendre que
là où les questions de harcèlement scolaire n'étaient pas du tout vraiment une préoccupation des enseignants à mon époque, j'ai cru comprendre que ça devenait davantage une question que les enseignants se posent.
Qu'est-ce que le Pacte pour l'enseignement d'excellence, qu'est-ce que votre législature se pose comme défi vis-à-vis du harcèlement scolaire ?
Ben d'abord, je voudrais dire que c'est vraiment sans doute un des sujets qui me préoccupent le plus parce que, alors malheureusement, on n'a pas des chiffres très fiables sur la question, ça fait partie du problème.
C'est difficile, hein.
Mais souvent, on entend le chiffre de un élève sur trois en Fédération de Bruxelles qui est impliqué dans des phénomènes de harcèlement, ce qui est immense.
Et franchement, c'est pas du tout empirique ce que je vais dire, mais quand je vois le nombre de courriers que je reçois de parents, etc.
Qui ne s'en sortent pas à une situation de harcèlement,
je mesure à quel point c'est un enjeu. Et parmi les choses les plus compliquées que j'ai eues à faire dans ma vie de ministre, me retrouver face à face avec des parents dont un enfant s'est suicidé
suite à des problèmes de harcèlement, ça fait vraiment partie des choses qui m'ont empêchée de dormir pendant plusieurs nuits quoi.
Et donc les écoles se trouvent extrêmement démunies face à ces phénomènes, qui parfois en plus se prolongent via du cyberharcèlement en dehors de l'enceinte de l'école.
Donc parfois, il y a peu de prise de l'école elle-même. Ça fait des années que la Fédération de Bruxelles fait des choses et se préoccupe du phénomène, mais en même temps,
c'est pas suffisamment structurel, c'est pas suffisamment durable, etc.
Et donc, il est vraiment temps qu'on mette en place un cadre réglementaire qui permette à toutes les écoles de s'inscrire dedans et de s'activer pour lutter contre ce phénomène.
Parce que le point positif de tout ça quand même, c'est qu'il y a des choses à faire en termes de harcèlement qui fonctionnent.
Alors du coup, on va mettre une nouvelle politique en place. On est en train de finaliser le décret et on sera prêt en janvier 2023.
Le but, c'est de permettre aux écoles de s'inscrire dans un programme cadre d'action, avec une série d'actions spécifiques qu'elles devront mener obligatoirement.
Je pense par exemple à la formation de toute l'équipe pédagogique et des éducateurs, à la mise en place d'un cadre de parole régulé, une procédure de signalement obligatoire des phénomènes de cyberharcèlement, des choses comme ça.
Donc il y aura un cadre d'action minimal, plus des actions qu'elles pourront ajouter. C'est un programme qui devra obligatoirement s'étaler sur trois ans, plus deux ans de mise en autonomie.
Et le but évidemment de ce nouveau programme, c'est qu'on laisse pas les écoles
livrées à elles-mêmes là-dessus, parce qu'elles ont déjà beaucoup à faire par ailleurs,
mais qu'elles soient accompagnées d'un opérateur agréé, puisqu'on a plein d'associations qui sont déjà spécialisées dans la lutte contre le harcèlement et cyberharcèlement et qui travaillent déjà avec les écoles.
Donc, on va agréer une série d'opérateurs et faire en sorte que ces opérateurs agréés envoient un accompagnant pour mettre en place le programme d'action avec l'école.
Donc, que l'école soit soutenue et aidée là-dedans pendant trois ans et puis, pendant deux ans, elle lâchera un peu du lest et on les suivra à distance pour les rendre complètement autonomes à la fin.
Le but, c'est vraiment ça, de les rendre complètement autonomes. Et donc, on va commencer avec deux cents premières écoles en 2023 sur base d'un appel à candidatures.
Parce qu'il faut se rendre compte que jusqu'ici, il y a plein de choses qui se passent dans les écoles, mais que c'est plic ploc sur base d'un appel à projet.
Donc il y a pas de suivi de ça, ça dépend de la bonne volonté de chacun. Il y a un shopping dans les opérateurs qui interviennent.
Enfin, aujourd'hui, c'est satisfaisant à aucun point de vue et pour aucun acteur. Donc voilà, il est temps vraiment de mettre un cadre.
Et on a vraiment pris le temps, ça arrive un peu tardivement dans la législature, mais on a pris le temps de lire tout ce qui a été fait sur le sujet, de rencontrer tous les experts en la matière pour vraiment finaliser.
Et alors, à côté de ça, qui est le programme d'action qui va être mis en place dans les écoles, on va créer un observatoire du climat scolaire.
Parce que l'idée, c'est aussi de se dire, on ne va pas lutter juste contre le harcèlement ou le cyberharcèlement. On veut vraiment améliorer le climat scolaire de manière générale et travailler
de manière connexe sur des questions comme la justice scolaire, et oui, le bien-être à l'école de manière générale, la démocratie scolaire, etc.
Parce que c'est dans des écoles où le climat scolaire est positif, en fait, on voit qu'il y a peu ou pas de phénomènes de harcèlement.
Donc tout est lié. Donc cet observatoire du climat, il va être chargé de faire la veille scientifique sur la question.
Parce que je disais qu'on a un problème de données. On a un problème de, oui, de—
Mais ce problème de données vient, entre autres choses, du fait que c'est très difficile pour les personnes qui sont cibles, victimes de harcèlement, d'en parler ou de pas vouloir se refermer sur elles-mêmes.
Donc comment est-ce qu'on résout ce problème de données si les personnes n'ont pas envie d'en parler ?
Ben donc, d'où la nécessité d'abord de mettre en place, évidemment, au sein des écoles, un procédé de signalement, un endroit où réceptionner la parole, des professionnels formés à résoudre des conflits.
Objectivement, j'ai eu l'occasion de visiter une série de choses qui sont en place et qui fonctionnent bien.
C'est pas insoluble, hein, il y a des méthodes qui fonctionnent aujourd'hui pour lutter contre le harcèlement.
Et plus on s'en préoccupe tôt, c'est-à-dire, c'est souvent, allez, entre cinquième primaire et deuxième secondaire qu'on est vraiment dans le cœur des difficultés en matière de harcèlement.
Plus on s'en préoccupe tôt, plus on instaure des bons réflexes chez les enfants, plus on va dénouer des problèmes dans le temps.
Donc c'est vraiment, pour moi, un des combats essentiels de cette législature. C'est un phénomène qu'on ne peut plus sous-estimer.
Oui. Dernier point avant de se quitter. Donc la question de la mixité sociale, je le disais, on en parlait au début de notre entretien.
Les fameux tests PISA en Belgique, franchement, sont assez médiocres. Non pas parce que tout est à jeter, puisqu'il y a des écoles qui se débrouillent très très bien, mais d'autres écoles se débrouillent moins bien.
Et on a une situation où il y a certaines écoles qui sont très prisées, très perçues comme étant les élites et perçues comme étant les meilleures écoles.
Et c'est là qu'on a pu voir, il y a une dizaine d'années, une quinzaine d'années, des files, puisque tout le monde voulait envoyer ses enfants là-bas.
Concrètement, qu'est-ce que le tronc commun, qu'est-ce que le Pacte pour l'enseignement d'excellence va résoudre en ce qui concerne, voilà, la mixité sociale ? Je vais y arriver.
Mais donc effectivement, d'abord, le constat de départ est très juste. Si on est mauvais dans PISA, c'est pas parce qu'on forme des mauvais élèves, c'est parce que la différence entre nos très bons élèves et ceux qui sont complètement
en décrochage de notre système scolaire est beaucoup trop grand et que les élèves qui échouent le plus sont beaucoup trop des élèves qui, au départ, sont dans une situation socio-économique défavorable.
Donc, il y a une corrélation trop grande entre le niveau socio-économique et les résultats. Donc ça, c'est vraiment à ça exactement que le pacte veut s'attaquer.
C'est même quelque chose auquel beaucoup de parents sont attachés, en fait, hein. Ce côté des écoles assez élitistes, bien bourgeoises, bien comme il faut, tout ça.
Oui, tout à fait. C'est vraiment un des problèmes. Je dirais que la liberté garantie par la Constitution de choix des établissements vient heurter—
Est un obstacle, oui, oui.
Directement, en fait, l'idéal de mixité sociale parfait. Donc voilà, ça, c'est déjà, on doit fonctionner avec ce cadre.
Ben, le décret inscription essaye au moins de mettre tous les élèves sur un pied d'égalité en termes d'accès à l'inscription, ce qui n'était pas le cas avant.
Mais voilà, on sait bien que c'est insuffisant. Donc, ce qu'on essaie de faire au travers du pacte et de tout ce qui va avec, la mise en œuvre du tronc commun.
J'ai parlé tout à l'heure de l'accompagnement personnalisé, j'ai parlé des pôles territoriaux qui vont aider les enfants à besoins spécifiques.
J'ai pas parlé du dispositif FLA, donc Français Langue d'Apprentissage, qui vient aussi en soutien des enfants qui maîtrisent pas suffisamment la langue d'enseignement.
Donc toutes ces aides mises ensemble doivent faire en sorte qu'on accroche au maximum les enfants, plus le renforcement des savoirs de base dont je parlais tout à l'heure au début de la scolarité.
Le but, c'est vraiment qu'on arrive,
à faire en sorte de faire davantage réussir des enfants qui sont en difficulté,
qu'elles soient sociales, qu'elles soient d'apprentissage, qu'elles soient de langue, puisque c'est quand même un des gros gros obstacles aussi.
C'est logique. Mais qu'est-ce qui est mis en œuvre ?
Aussi, un truc dont j'ai pas du tout parlé, mais qui est important, on a rendu obligatoire la scolarité à cinq ans parce qu'en termes d'égalité des chances, c'est quelque chose qui est très très important.
Pas qu'on avait un mauvais taux de scolarisation dans l'enseignement maternel, hein, on était quand même déjà à nonante-sept pour cent des enfants de cinq ans qui y étaient.
Mais par contre, ce qu'on remarquait, c'est que, et spécialement dans les quartiers populaires, les enfants inscrits à l'école fréquentaient pas toujours l'école de manière régulière.
Or, c'est aussi une des clés pour acquérir les codes de la vie à l'école avant l'entrée en primaire, c'est de pouvoir aller à l'école de manière régulière.
Et donc, c'est ça qui change, en fait, avec la scolarité obligatoire, c'est que les enfants de cinq ans sont aujourd'hui soumis à obligation scolaire comme les enfants de primaire et de secondaire.
C'est-à-dire qu'ils doivent justifier leurs absences. S'ils viennent pas à l'école, la Fédération Wallonie-Bruxelles tombe sur les parents, etc.
Et donc ça, c'est essentiel parce qu'en fait, les inégalités scolaires, elles démarrent là. Donc, un enfant,
qui a déjà fait toute une année d'enseignement maternel, il va être déjà beaucoup mieux armé pour entamer ses primaires.
Et donc voilà comment est-ce qu'on veut lutter de manière générale contre l'échec scolaire qui est vraiment au cœur des dispositifs.
On a revu aussi le décret inscription. On a encore essayé de rajouter une petite,
une petite touche dans le calcul des indices composites pour un peu renforcer la mixité, mais on sait bien que,
tant que les parents, évidemment, auront fondamentalement le choix, il y a des phénomènes naturels de regroupement qui sont difficiles à éviter.
Et du coup, le vrai défi, c'est de faire en sorte que, de garantir au maximum que toutes les écoles forment suffisamment bien les élèves pour leur futur, qu'il soit professionnel ou qu'il soit vers des études supérieures.
Donc, c'est-à-dire garantir un niveau de qualité suffisant partout au sortir de la sixième secondaire. Alors, pour ça-
C'est pas la question de la mixité sociale, ça. Si, si, si on peut maintenir une mixité sociale absolument nulle, mais que toutes les écoles sont de très bonnes écoles,
ça ne résout pas la question de la mixité sociale qui est elle-même un problème.
Non, non, c'est tout à fait exact. J'dirais que le principal obstacle, comme je vous l'ai dit, c'est la Constitution ou alors il faut, euh-
Donc on en parle, c'est ça que vous dites.
Par exemple, pour faire une carte scolaire comme en France aujourd'hui, moi, j'ai pas les leviers.
C'est certain.
Donc, voilà. Donc, on--
Je pense qu'on a fait un pas en avant avec le décret inscription, malgré, voilà, toutes les critiques qu'on peut entendre,
dans le fait que aujourd'hui, n'importe quel parent peut faire le choix d'une école et postuler, on va dire candidater à une école
que le directeur ou la directrice ne peut pas dire : Non merci, votre candidature m'intéresse pas, quoi.
S'il a le CEB, il peut être inscrit si, s'il est dans les conditions. C'est déjà... Alors, c'est pas, ça ne fait pas tout.
Après, il faut faire en sorte que les enfants qui ont accès à des écoles auxquelles ils n'avaient pas accès avant puissent poursuivre leur scolarité dans ces écoles, y réussir, etc.
Donc l'enjeu de l'accrochage de ces enfants est vraiment fondamental. Je voulais dire encore un petit mot parce que je disais que garantir
un niveau d'enseignement suffisamment bon dans toutes nos écoles, c'est évidemment le défi.
On a une série d'écoles qui sont considérées comme en écart significatif de performance par rapport à des écoles du même quartile, donc c'est-à-dire de environnement socioéconomique égal.
On a des écoles qui décrochent en termes de résultats. Alors, c'est calculé sur base de différents critères.
C'est pas que les résultats scolaires, c'est aussi le taux d'absentéisme des profs, etc. Et donc ces écoles-là où les voyants sont rouges, on a décidé de les aider d'une manière particulière.
C'est-à-dire que je vous ai expliqué que chaque école, chacune des deux mille cinq cents écoles de la Fédération de Bruxelles, doit faire un plan de pilotage.
Pour ces écoles-là qui sont en dispositif d'ajustement, on leur retire un peu d'autonomie, c'est-à-dire qu'il y a un audit qui est fait dans l'école, etc.
Et des ressources, de l'aide externe pour faire face à la situation. Parce qu'en général, ce sont des écoles qui cumulent tellement de difficultés, souvent d'ordre social, mais pas que,
qu'on a considéré qu'il fallait un coup de pouce externe à ces écoles, sans volonté, évidemment, de les stigmatiser.
D'ailleurs, elles se sont-- y a pas de classement de ces écoles connues, etc. Donc, elles sont, elles,
c'est confidentiel, mais c'est important de dire que vingt écoles par an sont identifiées comme étant tellement en difficulté qu'elles doivent bénéficier d'un coup de pouce supplémentaire pour être repositionnées.
Caroline Désir, merci beaucoup pour ces un peu plus de Septante Minutes passées ensemble.
Merci à vous.
Je vous dis à très bientôt. Au revoir.
Au revoir.
Pour ne rien manquer, n'oubliez pas de suivre Septante Minutes Avec sur votre plateforme de podcast préférée ainsi que sur les réseaux sociaux.
Tous les liens sont en description. Quant à moi, je vous dis à très bientôt. Salut salut !